my name is star two hours daddy named me  then garden Heights mama and daddy says  our life is here because our people are  here the high school is where you go to  get jump high or pregnant we don't go  there Williamson is another world so  when I'm here I'm starvation too until  the weekend comes around I get those  goosebumps every time oh no no you  out of the car you know start okay go  back where he told you come on I'm not  playing go back today garden Heights is  reeling after the shooting of a 17 year  old black teenager by a white police  officer violence brutality we live in a  complicated world it doesn't seem that  complicated to you it's about more than  just color  it's about black people poor people  everybody at the bottom I need to speak  for him  when you're ready to talk you talk I  never let nobody make you be quiet I  named you star by acid  [Music]